[Music]
your instructor is one of the finest
pilots this program has ever produced
[Music]
his exploits
are legendary
what he has to teach you they very well
mean
the difference between life and death
your reputation precedes you have to
admit i wasn't expecting an invitation
back
they're called orders maverick
[Music]
good morning aviators this is your
captain speaking today's exercise is dog
fighting
two versus what he's gotta be kidding
[Music]
smoking the aircraft
so
the past isn't dead
james fate draws us back together
[Music]
now your enemy is my enemy
his name is saffin and what does he want
revenge me when our secret finds its way
out
it'll be the death of you
you can imagine why i've come back to
play
there's a young lady in santiago i want
you to meet you're late
when you're ready
i met your new double-oh she's a
disarming young woman
i get why you shot him yeah well
everyone tries at least once
james bond
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place i just
want to be a little
tidier
come on bond hell are you
do you have a flow of this nope
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
what is it you don't know what this is
he's going to kill millions
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
[Music]
there's something happening to me
there's something awakening in my mind i
can't control it
what did you see
there's a crusade coming
[Applause]
do you often dream things that happen
just as you dream them
yes
the test is simple remove your hand from
the box
and you die what's in the box
pain
[Applause]
you inherit too much power you have
proven you can rule yourself
now you must learn to rule others
something none of your ancestors learnt
my father rules an entire planet he's
losing it
he's getting a richer one you'll lose
that one too
arrakis is a death trap
this is an extermination
[Applause]
they're picking my family off one by one
let's fight my demons
an animal caught in a trap will gnaw off
its own leg
to escape what will you do
[Music]
i know you
one day the legend will be born
all of civilization depends on it
the future i can see it
i must not fear
is the mind killer hello duke
where the fear is gone only i will
remain
go go go
what do you got there oh it's just my
wife emma this is my son charlie
enjoy a lot less well last nothing
happier than the wife
of a new detective that was cool man
she's different you know my wife
you give a woman 600 tuesdays
it ain't worth three saturday nights how
much money you got a lot
how many problems you got a lot how many
people doubted your life all available
units
are down detective banks in route
whoever did this has another motive
[Music]
they're targeting cops
this shit's gonna go sideways fast
someone's out there pulling all the
strings
you want to play games [ __ ]
[Music]
are you ready this is the main event
he's coming
whoa
come get some of this
who wants a selfie tentacular
i've got your whole life story tattooed
on my body
yeah in a long history of monster
wrestling there has never been a
champion quite like detective
fans around the world are asking is
there a challenger out there with the
hunger
to drive the discipline to become the
next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
did he eat thank you
that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what yeah that's gonna be a hard no for
me
[Music]
oh do it again
[Music]
[Music]
i tell people my sister moved out west
you're a science teacher
your husband he renovates houses
you're thinking about moving but you're
gonna wait until the interest rates go
down
that's not my story
before i was an avenger i made mistakes
[Applause]
and a lot of enemies
his call signs taskmaster he controls
the red room
they're manipulated fully conscious but
no choices
i should have come back for you how many
others are there
enough
[Applause]
we have to go back to where it all
started so they never do that to anyone
again
we're family we fight with you
you won't win i've always found the best
to look into the past
okay you got a plan or shall i just stay
dug and cover my plan was to drive us
away
gloria plan sucks
[Music]
at some point we all have to choose
between what the world wants you to be
need my choice
i'm done running
[Music]
here's what's gonna happen natasha don't
slouch i'm not sludging you're gonna get
the back hunch
listen to your mother oh my god all
right enough
all of you i didn't say anything that's
not fair
what is going
[Music]
it's
on
it's okay it's okay we're okay we're
okay
okay where where where mom
[Music]
so
[Applause]
run
[Applause]
i don't know why he came all the way up
here there's nothing left
please there are people out there
the people that are left another kind of
people worth saving
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clever
give me some shell i gotcha
ah
[Applause]
[Music]
my whole life i trained to become a
guardian of the dragon gem
but this world has changed
[Music]
and its people are divided
now to restore peace i must find
the last dragon
my name is raya
[Music]
you're getting a little too big for this
bud
[Music]
good morning goldie my name is guy and i
live
in free city i have everything i need
[Music]
except one thing hey
excuse me
hey bud you ever think that there's got
to be more more than what
stuff we do day after day literally not
once
today's gonna be different goldie what
are we looking at
who are you we ran into each other the
other day how did you find me i waited
outside by the murder train guy i have
to tell you something
there is no easy way to say this this
world it's a video game
i really want to kiss you is that weird
listen to me you're not real
wait you let who kiss you guy there's
not a button for that
oh he found the button
buddy if we're not real doesn't that
mean that nothing you do matters
i am sitting here with my best friend
trying to help him get through a tough
time
now if that's not real i don't know what
it is
millie i know this world is just a game
but this place these people that's all i
have
thanks guys who is this guy this
character in the video game free city
has been turning heads
by being the good guy who is blue shirt
guy you're absolutely right who is he
or she indeed this loser is ruining the
game man
i don't care if he's arnold freaking
schwarzenberger
terminate him
we're doing great guy in two days the
game is gonna shut down
you this whole city they'll be gone what
if we can save it
[Music]
was that cool it felt really cool we
could change our world but we have to
fight together
i don't even know what's happening right
now but i love it this is the first time
i've ever driven a car before
i really wish you'd mentioned that yeah
[Music]
they seem nice
the romance of the desert
has the power to set use
[Music]
i ask you
[Music]
have you ever loved so much
been so possessed by jealousy
[Music]
[Applause]
that you might kill
[Music]
is one of you i don't feel safe here
i don't feel safe with any of them it's
too late
to change events it's time to face
the consequences i have investigated
many crimes
but this
[Music]
has altered the shape of my soul
i am detective and i will deliver your
killer
how many great stories are tragedies
[Applause]
michael i've known you since you were a
child
you the gift you always have
if there's an answer to the disease
you'll find it
should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
i have a rare blood disease and i'm not
out of time
this could be my last chance
you're up to something what is it that's
not exactly legal
i don't want to see you get hurt more
than you already have
this would be a cure
at what cost
[Music]
i went from time feel like more alive
than ever
increased strength and speed
[Music]
the ability to use echolocation
even overpowering urge to consume blood
[Music]
how far are we allowed to go fix
something that's broken
until the remedy
is worse than the disease
michael morbius got tired of doing the
whole good guy thing
what's up doc
that was a terrible crash
well i'll get to be alive
[Music]
stop don't come any closer it's a girl
it's so loud here we call it the noise
happened to all the men on this planet
every thought in our heads
on display
where are all the women
the dead
[Music]
why is she thinking where the hell is
her noise it's strange to see everything
you're thinking it was strange for me
too not knowing what's going on in your
head
i mean i know you might not like my dog
or you want to hit me over the head with
a rock or something
i like your dog he's stronger than he
knows
you better watch your noise
those men catch you they'll kill you
[Music]
if you want to protect the girl you have
to leave now
with her power there's no telling what
he can do
i need that girl before she wants him
how many are coming 100
200 thousands
come on
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate that has no fault lines
no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily
under the dining basis now
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica a replica of what
a ghost trap
[Music]
there hasn't been a go sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead your dad never mentioned
this to you
it's just my mom
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rebel of
his life
wait a minute
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it fate
[Music]
call it lock
call it karma
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling has a gunner seat
[Music]
[Music]
hey where you going i thought we were
going fishing
you're welcome
a sequel how original
you must heed my words before i'm gone
my son
[Music]
now you will be king
but the throne must pass to a male heir
hakeem it appears you have a
son who must be found prepare the royal
jet
we are going back to america oh hell no
your majesty
come on
say it again
well well say it again
[Music]
it is so good to see you well abby damn
look who done come up in here
hey and ebola and blood diamonds nelson
mandela and winning those hungry babies
with the flies on the face
that's too much now you stepped over the
line now we won't be talking that kind
of [ __ ] about the hungry babies you're
going to get out of my chair politically
incorrect
so what you doing back here hotel rwanda
yeah i'm back
[Music]
so what are you doing out here
there is a legend in the jungles of the
amazon
of a tree that heals all it could change
the world
but if it gets into the wrong hands it
could awaken
a great evil i believe that the legend
is real
and i'm gonna find it what you want when
i do just imagine the lives that could
be saved
i've been looking for this tree longer
than anybody
i've tracked a legend to every village
every island nothing
you're searching for something that
can't be found
but you've never had the key
let's do something that's safe let's go
see some elephants there are no
elephants in the amazon and i don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants
know this about the jungle everything
that you see
wants to kill you and can
careful they could smell fear i am not
afraid
oh my gosh who brings a submarine to the
amazon
good night
frank get it hold on come on i got it i
don't got it no no no no no no
just leave me alone that was a disaster
didn't go the way i planned
[Music]
my flock this will not be
a war of heroes
nations will slaughter each other
this is going to be fun
[Applause]
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world burns
son the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something
certainly
we are the first independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal civilized
but merciless
welcome to the club very clever it's
time
to pour fuel
on the fire of revolution
yes my shepherd
welcome englishman
rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
let's end this as gentlemen after all
manners
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
[Music]
you knew him didn't you then you had
that one little feeling
but you waved it away
you should have listened to that one
little feeling
just like i'm listening to you now you
can talk to me
i'm all a friend
you're not exactly a department favorite
thing's probably changed a lot since you
left
you still got to catch them right yeah
not that much exchange then right
i can assure you all we are taking a 24
7 all hands on deck approach to these
cases
guy's a shark if he stops he dies he
likes to drive probably has a decent car
maybe two
high mileage they must really like my
car
i do how's the trunk space
something i gotta know has a guy with
the best clearance rate in the
department work 15 years without a
promotion
maybe i didn't go to the right church
when i look in your eyes what i see
it ain't good
he knew all the details but he wasn't
within 10 miles of the killing
why is that
how's the trunk space
[Music]
what do you want i want to nail the
bastard for
all of the girls he killed
[Music]
i want to know him too difference is
i'm doing this for me
[Music]
it's little things jimmy so little
things that rip you apart is the little
things that
get you caught
what is storytelling
storytelling started with our indigenous
people
can anyone give me an example of a myth
or a story they're afraid of
lucas
what's going on we found a part of a man
in the woods today
[Music]
part of the man i guess the other half
was found
in the mine
well this has got to be an animal right
[Music]
no animal that i've ever seen
something is going on with lucas
these drawings belongs to a student of
mine
this is what was in the mind
[Music]
it's a diabolical spirit
excuse me this is a myth for you
always
he's not
[Music]
god
he's here
[Music]
after a lifetime of being the world's
most famous
[Music]
in the big city
[Music]
this hotel has been host to four
presidents three popes two kings
and we're about to host the wedding of
the century do you think you're
qualified to take on this position i
shine under pressure
like a diamond or rihanna one other
thing
we have a mouse problem with the what
now i'll catch it sir
gonna shine like this don't even
gotta try oh wow this is so detailed
we could hire an exterminator or we can
leverage
millions of years of predatory evolution
[Applause]
if a picture of this mouse is tweeted
out to insta book face or ticky talk
we will be ruined no sir that's not
gonna happen
that rodent is toast
i will not let this hotel be ruined by a
cat in a mouth
he's dying with us
i think i might have just pulled this
off
oh
[Music]
suenito it means
little dream
that's it no story
all right all right everybody sit down
sit down it's a story of a block
that was disappearing
[Music]
called washington heights the streets
were made of music
and you probably never heard my
[Music]
on these blocks you can't walk two steps
without bumping into
someone's big plan i'm making moves i'm
making deals
but guess what what you still ain't got
no skills
[Music]
i've been saving up all my pennies in my
piggy bank for this day
this is going to be an emotional roller
coaster the odds are against you
but there's a chance right
[Music]
a dream isn't some sparkly diamond
there's no shortcuts sometimes
it's rough
the world spins around while i'm frozen
to my seat
they're talking about kicking out all
the dreamers but every day is different
make some noise
[Music]
just listen little details
that tell the world we are not invisible
[Music]
y'all
[Music]
so we cannot stop this
deputy chairman fred hampton of the
illinois black panther party
[Applause]
repeat after me
[Applause]
you're looking at 18 months
for the stolen car five years for
impersonating a federal officer
[Music]
or you can go home
the black panthers are forming a rainbow
coalition
of oppressed brothers and sisters of
every color their aim
is to show hatred and inspire terror i
will learn all that i care
these ain't no terrorists you can mother
liberate if you can't murder liberation
you're the murderer revolutionary but
you can't murder revolution
i need to murder a freedom fighter but
you can't learn
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i love my life i love you so much gary
i'll never forget the day we met
[Music]
ready hello little snail what's your
name
scary huh do you want to be friends
me too gary
i'm home gary gare bear
[Music]
this summer the search begins friends
don't let friends go on dangerous quests
[Music]
with all new faces
hello call me sage good morning i'm made
out of sage and i am a sage
so it works out pretty well i'm patrick
my name means
toaster in celtic pretty sure it doesn't
the most amazing places
the lost city of atlantic city boy i
hope we don't lose focus
look i wouldn't worry about us losing
[Music]
that's not an l that's a seven seven
starts with an l
that's weird the spongebob movie
sponge on the run this is gonna be like
a buddy movie oh i love your sense of
irony patrick
thank you i love my sense of ironing too
[Music]
is anyone hungry yes starving i'm on it
i'm just going to wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing well
la deeta i didn't realize i was with a
bunch of sophisticates
families can come in all shapes and
sizes that's why i also feature having
some two-legged children
join them roll it imagine me and our
future children
frolicking this is fun i'm speeding up a
little
i'm speeding up quite a bit
i think he's getting the hang of it
tommy no those are mr mcgregor's
i swear if it wasn't for me peter just
leave my tomatoes alone you have
everything else honestly my kids will be
so much better behaved go easy on him
as soon as they have a baby we're done
for
maybe we're better off without them
don't stare at the scenery rushing by
look at a fixed point on the horizon and
just lock your eyes onto that
[Music]
i love this place what's for lunch
there's a magical place with the ripest
radishes
the sweetest corn it's called the
farmer's market
and if you want an overpriced gift that
will never be used they sell lavender
scented bath bombs
this sounds a bit dodgy i would never
put you in danger
i promise okay i can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place are you in
are you out
we're in run
no let them go my family's in trouble
and i'm gonna get them back the other
rabbits were taken
and the pig and the hedgehog and the
badger
let's go get the others why are you even
helping me
that's what a dad does
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no cottontail just discovered sugar
we had a good
run i'm gonna live forever
[Music]
you brothers you could move mountains
without lifting a finger
minister malcolm x good news the chariot
is coming
who's mcgregor that's right jim brown
takes the ball your record is going to
stand the test of time
all together
the entire city of miami is celebrating
i'm the new heavyweight champion of the
world and i don't even have a scratch on
my face
oh my goodness okay why am i so pretty
hey congratulations jim
this movement that we are in is called a
struggle
because we are fighting for our lives
this ain't about civil rights they ain't
giving black people what they really
want
what's that hey i was made in america
that's why i'm not here
power black power i like the sound of
that
i wish i lived in america we have to be
there for each other
everybody rich all i gotta do is
do you know what we wouldn't have found
if we would have stayed on the trail
the waterfall
what is that oh my god
[Music]
it's a story people know but don't talk
about
in whispers like a ghost story
[Music]
we don't bother them
and they don't bother us
[Music]
but anyone who goes up there what is
this place
they don't come back
[Music]
it's happened before
[Music]
descendants of these people are still
living up there on the mountain
they said they would be the foundation
on which a new nation would be built
[Music]
if you stray outside the designated
areas you will be removed from the
island
it's recommended you wear a hijab when
visiting your client we've had incidents
of inmates spitting at female lawyers
you want to represent the head recruiter
for 9 11.
muhammadu also the mauritanian feld in
guantanamo
you recruited the guys who flew your
friend's plane into the south tower
he put those men on my husband's plane
i'm gonna make him pay an event the
detainee lunges for you push back away
from the table we'll get in there as
quick as we can
[Music]
i'm nancy hollander this is my associate
we wish to represent you
we are seeking the death penalty but if
we miss something this guy goes home
let's get to it call this number speak
to my mother
tell her i don't know something nice
the us government is holding upwards of
700 prisoners clinton taco
since when did we start locking people
up without a trial in this country
that's a lot of case styles the
prosecution won't show us the evidence
they have against you
it's all redacted we had a problem take
it up with the government
all my time here i've been told you are
guilty not for something that i have
done but because of suspicions
and associations i am innocent he has
been interrogated he has been held
against his will
for six years without a single charge
being laid against him
doesn't bother you at all working for
something like this i'm not just
defending him i'm defending the rule of
law
you haven't seen what i've seen
where i'm from in mauritania we know not
to trust the police
but never did i believe that the united
states of america would use
fear and terror to control me a couple
suitless nights that's all
i've never been part of a conspiracy but
i'm starting to think
this is what it must feel like to be on
the outside you're overthinking this
either wear the jersey or get off the
field
you need to tell me what happened to you
i can't defend you do you understand
that
you asked me to set fire to this place
but i'm still
maybe he's guilty maybe he is like we're
doing our job i'm not welcome home
that's not a part of my job
if i'm wrong when it comes to my record
and i'm the one who have to add support
what makes you think you're any better
than the rest of us i don't think i'm
better than anybody else that is
supportive for eight years i have been
dreaming of being in a courtroom
now that i'm here i'm scared to death
you know i think i figured out
why they built guantanamo down there
my client he's not a suspect he's a
witness
mr slahi would you please raise your
right hand and repeat after me
[Music]
the mauritanian
[Music]
this is your last careers lesson so does
anyone
have a realistic career plan tyson
denzel what about you
youtubers i keep telling you all you've
got to keep things real
jamie jamie knew
me what do you want to be a performer
you remember when we was little can we
use flair dress up
well for me that's a game i don't want
to stop playing
i'm done with this i wanted a song so
badly
i got you the cold empty morning
i don't think i've got a dad anymore
you've done nothing wrong jamie you
never did
so why do you want to be on stage i want
to be a drag queen
because it's all i ever dreamed of and
when i closed my eyes it's all i can see
[Music]
if jamie wants to come to prom may come
stressed just like all the other boys
you are a freak they made me feel so
ugly
i'm scared you can't just be a violent
dress jamie
obama dress is something to blast out
a drag queen should be feared you won't
believe the power it gives you i don't
just want to be one i have to be one
stop waiting for permission
you are the bravest person i know you're
like beyonce
no
do you ever wish i were just normal
no never
[Applause]
and you don't even know it you aim so
tidy i don't know how you do it i don't
have as many dresses as you do
[Music]
you